bonjour à tous et bienvenue donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes vendredi
vendredi c'est le raccourci entre jeudi
et vendredi c'est un nouveau jour qu'on
vous invente
déjà bah oui déjà 5h56 elle est de
retour Lorraine ça va mieux
en pleine forme
je voudrais je voudrais rendre ici un
hommage à celui qui nous a quitté
aujourd'hui
celui qui aura été un fidèle compagnon
de nos journées malades ce petit ange
parti trop tôt salto le Netflix français
le Netflix français c'est fini tu es
parti
contre 10 euros par mois de voir des
contenus qui étaient gratuits sur le
replay des chaînes
quand l'idée du son là était venu quand
l'idée du vendredi là
parce que c'est jeudi mais c'est un peu
vendredi déjà on est d'accord donc le
vendredi est un nouveau jour
bonsoir madame c'est un gros gros souci
dites-moi votre gros gros problème
il vous manque un morceau de votre pénis
on va on va s'occuper du micro de
Marlène qui parce que vous avez en fait
je le dis pour ceux qui écoutent et qui
attendent c'est un blouson qui est en
quelle matière c'est du cuir comme vous
dites
c'est une émission qui avait à l'époque
alors et le Queen il est en train de
faire
Éric voici votre première question
oui je le place je suis désolé Bruno
15000 euros 15000 € net d'impôts pour
vous rien que pour vous sur votre compte
en banque c'est 15000 euros et après
vous n'avez qu'à les dépenser comme vous
en avez envie mais pour les gagner il
faut répondre correctement à cette
question petit fruit du chêne S1 le coin
le fruit du chêne ou deux le gland quel
est le fruit du chêne un pour le coin 2
pour le gland
vous voyez est-ce que c'est du poivre
blanc
et j'ai aussi mis la poudre de cacao non
non monsieur il faut
déchiré et là là aussi c'était vos
collègues qui sont venus en ambulance
tout le monde a sa chance les amis je le
dis souvent c'est à dire que vous là ce
soir en envoyant la bonne réponse vous
allez peut-être gagner 15000 € bonne
chance à tous
je peux m'exprimer ainsi c'est pas tous
les jours qu'on croise un gland à 15000
€ un conseil
lâchez nos utérus si
vous souhaitez si vous souhaitez
c'était salariale le congé paternité
équivalent au congé maternité laissez
partir les femmes avant 64 ans novembre
ne sont pas la variable d'ajustement de
votre réforme des retraites la vie c'est
pas le monde des bisounours il y a
toujours un truc qui va pas et cette
attaque dirigée contre les députés RN
n'a pas plu à Jean-Philippe Tanguy le
portefeuille officiel de Marine Le Pen
on en revient à débat complètement
caricatural où vous faisait croire qu'on
veut assigner les femmes à je ne sais
quel foyer mais c'est nous qui avons
voulu envoyer une femme deux fois
l'Élysée alors on recevra tout à l'heure
pourquoi les hommes tournent toujours
sur des uns par deux ouh
c'est Fabien de l'être qui a écrit ça et
il est pourquoi les femmes tombent
toujours sur des kners
[Rires]
je suis là on entend pas bien vous
n'avez pas rester comme ça il nous dit
et on était et oui oui puis l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes fait un
pas de plus une étude menée par une
douzaine de chercheurs ouvre la voie à
une pilule contraceptive pour les hommes
les premiers tests sur les souris
professionnels efficacité à 100% elles
seront testées sur des humains d'ici à
2026 grosse voiture petit pénis
urbaine et que là ils ont fait une vraie
étude qui confirme que semblerait que
les personnes ayant de plus petit pénis
soit attirés par les voitures de sport
avait déjà 7 enfants et avec son mari
dit-elle on commençait à réfléchir à en
faire un huitième de la réflexion ils
sont passés à l'action et c'est là que
l'histoire devient dingue Dominica est
tombé enceinte de quintuplé 5b qui ont
vu le jour oui le 14 février pour la
Saint-Valentin j'ai tout le détail en
trois filles et deux garçons qui
s'appellent Ariana Daisy Charles Patrick
Elizabeth May et Angeline rose
si vous rajoutez deux prénoms déjà ça
fait double après on peut le dire avoir
un petit pénis c'est pas si grave
c'est grave non c'est une belle bagnole
j'adore j'adhère je dis oui je dis à
love it ce soir ils doivent pour la
première fois partager un lit deux
places une situation plutôt inhabituelle
pour le patron et son employé qui semble
un peu gêné bon bah ça y est comment on
fait les jambes
de couchage toute façon je garde le
caleçon
j'espère bien j'espère bien que vous
gardez le caleçon l'actrice américaine
Raquel Welch sexe symbole des années 60
et 70 est morte paisiblement après une
courte maladie a fait savoir sa famille
elle avait été révélée par le film un
million d'années avant Jésus-Christ elle
a tourné dans une quarantaine de films
et les fans sont d'ailleurs venus saluer
sa mémoire sur Hollywood Boulevard dans
un instant nos invités de vider
Clémentine Célarié Jacky du Jacky show
entre autres mais de platine 45 surtout
l'oeil de Pierre levure les actualités
de Bertrand et j'étais à sa Zoé grognon
on vous